foreign
[Music]
policy Analyst at the National Institute
of Health for those of you that don't
know the NIH is the largest funder of
biomedical research in the world it
consists of 27 different institutes each
that each with a different focus on
human health
I work at one of those institutes the
National Institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
you may this guy may look familiar you
may even own a bobble head or a pair of
Dr fauci socks but he's been he's the
director of nyad and has been for almost
the past 40 years
and nayad's mission is to fund research
and infectious diseases biodefense and
immune mediated diseases such as Asthma
and Allergy
so a little bit about myself I was a
cancer researcher for a little bit for a
little over a decade I started at the
University of Arizona Cancer Center and
then I moved to the National Cancer
Institute in Bethesda Maryland and I'm I
tell you this because I beg you please
no infectious disease questions you'll
be disappointed
um but uh while at the NCI I developed a
love for science policy I then left the
lab and started a new position at niad
in the data analytics and research
branch and there I was introduced to R
and all of the tools and packages that
I'll be talking about today
so uh when I joined niad I joined a very
small team as me and two other analysts
and I kind of felt like this is what we
this is how I've felt the team once we
were small and Scrappy but we really
wanted to have an impact on you know a
large organization like nyad and today
I'm going to tell you about how we use
shiny to support nyad and make our team
a lot more efficient as well
so the first example I want to give you
is a shiny dashboard to hit research
funding targets
so why do we have funding targets for a
specific research area first we're a
government organization so Congress can
tell us we'd like you to to spend this
amount of money on This research area so
it can be congressionally mandated we
also sometimes receive targeted funding
aside from the NIH budget one example of
this recently was Operation warp speed
for coveted vaccine development
and finally night leadership can also
set funding funding goals based on
nyad's Mission and priorities at the
time
but when I first got involved in this
process I found out it was a lot more
complex than I originally imagined so in
some research areas that we're tracking
there are over 700 different projects
these are grants and contracts that
represent a lot of different moving
parts to give you an idea in some of
these areas we're tracking over half a
billion dollars worth of funding
and another added layer of complexity is
that at NIH we receive Grant
applications throughout the year so
we're stuck making you know important
funding decisions at the beginning of
the year when we don't have all of the
data available to us so we don't have
all the grants that we're going to fund
that year
but I wanted to use an analogy to help
understand this process so you can
imagine that hitting these research
funding targets are sort of like a road
trip right so on a road trip you have to
know exactly where you are at any given
point and how you're going to get to
your destination otherwise you're going
to get lost
but we all know it's not that easy
sometimes things come along that make it
difficult to get where you want to go
I'm thinking of one specific road trip I
took moving from Tucson to Bethesda
Maryland on this road trip I got a flat
tire my air conditioning broke in the
middle of a heat wave and I had a very
vocal very disgruntled cat in the back
seat for 2300 miles but today I want to
talk about the challenges that we faced
hitting these research funding targets
and how we use shiny to address those
challenges
so first
um like I said there's a lot of
different moving Parts there's a lot of
people involved in this process
throughout the Institute I immediately
found out that there were a lot of
competing estimates right everybody had
their own idea of where we were so it's
like if you're on a road trip and you
know you're in Dallas somebody else
thinks you're in El Paso and another
person thinks that you're in Utah and
nobody can agree on where you're CR
where you're at at the moment so it was
really frustrating
even worse is when people would come to
me with funding estimates and have no
details so it's like somebody saying
we're in Missouri and I'm like there's
no chance we're in Missouri you took a
wrong exit somewhere
um how did you get there and they would
have no idea so my team spent a lot of
time and effort trying to figure out how
they came to that conclusion and
comparing it to our estimate too
and finally at the beginning of this
process a lot of people were you know uh
reliant on spreadsheets and emails and
this is a big problem because you can
imagine that immediately once you send
that email that information is out of
date because at NIH we're constantly
getting new applications and making new
Awards throughout the year
so and also people make mistakes right
when you're searching your inbox maybe
you found that email from last week or
last month so it was hard to get
everybody on the same page
so I created the research area tracking
tool to help address address these
questions
but how does this dashboard get us
closer to our destination first behind
the scenes I have an R markdown document
that's pulling in data from multiple
different databases I use DB plier so I
never have to look at SQL coding again
and so it transforms it it formats it
and writes it to a database for our
shiny dashboard to use and because I
published it on rstudio connect I can
schedule it to run daily so that the
information is always up to date
so we've immediately made this process a
lot better right so we have data
integration multiple data sources in one
spot the information is always up to
date and people have one source that
they can go to for information kind of
like a Google Maps right
so next I want to Dr to address this
problem of having multiple estimates and
you know it seemed like everybody people
around the Institute had a little pieces
of the puzzle but we could never put
those together and get the big picture
so
um in the dashboard I made all of the
data available so every single you can
see every single project that's included
or not included in our estimate so this
is almost like having turn-by-turn
directions showing you exactly where we
are and how we're going to get to our
goal
we've made this data available to be
downloaded at any point for any user we
also wanted this to be a platform for
collaboration so you can add and remove
projects from the estimate as well
this is an example of that where you can
add a project and add a reason for that
change so that other users can see why
you made that change
and so that so that the data is always
up to date the shiny dashboard writes
all these user inputs to a database so
that
um you know whenever the whenever a user
logs on it's uh always up to date and
includes all of those user inputs as
well
so the benefit of this is that we've
increased transparency and collaboration
in this whole process and hopefully
we've gotten closer to our destination
so lastly I wanted the dashboard to be
able to make predictions based on an
application score
um so what NIH when an application comes
in it's uh it's basically reviewed by an
expert panel of scientists and they give
it a score that helps us determine
whether we fund it or not so this
dashboard can actually make predictions
on how much we're going to fund even
before we've made those Awards
and since this dashboard is based on
shiny reactivity all of the graphs the
tables the high level numbers everything
can can be changed based on user input
so we've allowed users to adjust that
scoring cut off as well so if you're in
a meeting saying I want to fund all of
the applications up to this score you
can actually change that in the
dashboard and see how it affects the
estimates so that you can make these
these important decisions in real time
so uh I hope that this dashboard has
made this process a lot easier and maybe
a little bit more accurate as well but I
think in the end my small team benefited
the most right because we've been able
to automate a lot of these processes and
uh really free us up to take on
additional projects right before we were
spending so much time uh you know
manually updating the data answering
questions from colleagues and making
changes that we didn't have that much
time to do other things
so the next uh example I want to give
you is how we've used machine learning
to classify nyad grants
so just a little background on grants at
NIH there are really two main types one
starts at NIH so we send out a request
for applications and this is when the
NIH
asks the scientific Community to apply
for funding in a very specific
well-defined area
we usually use these to stimulate
research and really high priority areas
um the next type of application is the
investigator initiated application so
instead of starting at NIH we're
starting with that investigator or
scientist that's running a lab somewhere
right so these make up the by far the
majority of our applications greater
than 85 percent and uh so at NIH we
really have to rely on the scientific
Community the creativity and Ingenuity
that they have to come up with
Innovative research ideas and those
ideas can be very Broad and
cross-cutting or very narrow and well
defined but when we get those
applications these investigator
initiated ones we don't have much
information on it besides that it falls
in the broad research areas of niad's
mission
so you can imagine that this is very
difficult right when you're dealing with
thousands of applications how do we know
how much we've funded and what projects
we funded in a specific research area
so we get questions all the time how
much have you spent on HIV vaccine
research or you know how much have you
spent on tuberculosis research and what
projects and we need to be able to
answer those questions
so how do we do that the answer is we
have a team the we have a team for that
so every year niad gets over 9 000 Grant
applications and we fund about 20 of
these give or take we then have a team
of about three to six people that go
through these awarded grants and apply
codes based on the research being
proposed so they have 1300 unique codes
over 1300 unique codes that they can use
to describe that research and I've
included a few examples here on the
right so they look are they researching
a specific disease like Ebola or zika is
the research area you know new
Therapeutics or Diagnostics and so on
but you can imagine with thousands of
Grants this can be challenging
um first it's very time intensive so
they have to go through uh thousands of
these awarded grants and read the title
The Abstract the specific games and
describe that research
because it's so time consuming we only
have the resources to code awarded
grants the 80 of applications that are
unfunded we don't have any information
on
and they have a constantly increasing
workload so every year we're getting
more applications and giving out more
Awards and especially at the beginning
of the pandemic this was we saw a huge
increase in applications due to coveted
research
and finally because it takes so much
time this usually isn't done until the
very end of the year so we don't have
real-time data on this which would be
helpful
so we thought this was a great
opportunity to use a supervised machine
learning for Grant classification we had
a database of thousands of grants that
have been manually coded over the past
decade that we could use to train
machine learning models so here's an
example of a grant that's proposing to
research a more sensitive diagnostic for
tuberculosis when I looked up the the
codes on this grant you could see the
disease was tuberculosis the research
area was Diagnostics and it was a
clinically focused Grant so I just want
to give you one example of how we've
used machine learning to classify grants
based on their research area so here it
was Diagnostics but there are five
categories including therapeutic
prevention and vaccine
so we took a
about 7 500 grants that have been
previously been manually coated and used
them to train three different machine
learning models including logistic
regression support Vector machine and
random Forest to compare the three
we then tested these models using about
3 200 grants that had also been manually
coded and so what we found was the
logistic regression was the most
accurate 88.5 percent and it also did
the best at predicting this relatively
small category of grants in the
prevention class
so we use this machine this logistic
regression model to build a shiny
dashboard for coding niad grants and we
we then expanded it to assist encoding
in five additional categories
so behind the scenes once again we have
an R markdown document that's pulling in
the data from multiple sources uh
making those machine learning
predictions and writing this data to a
database it's constantly getting updated
with new applications new Awards and
this is what our shiny dashboard uses
and we once again we wanted people to be
able to collaborate so uh it's writing
user inputs and a database for future
use
so here's an example of how we're using
those
um we're incorporating user feedback so
you can actually go through each project
and say whether it's relevant or not
relevant to that specific area
where we're including the machine
learning score so they know the
probability that that project is in that
area
and once again we wanted it to be a
platform for collaboration so you can
attach notes to each of these projects
for other users or even yourself in the
future
here's an example of that you see a tiny
little envelope when a note is attached
to your project we also have tags
involved so if you don't want to write a
whole note you can just add a small tag
or phrase for example if somebody has
verified that project you can just
quickly add that
so we're hoping that this project will
improve productivity so if previously it
took five minutes to code a grant we're
hoping with a machine learning
prediction and a probability estimate
that we can cut that time down and even
if it was one to two minutes you can
imagine that with thousands of Grants
that's a very significant Time Savings
we also want to support data-driven
decision making so as I mentioned 80 of
our applications are unfunded and
therefore not coded but with these
machine learning predictions we can
apply these codes to All Grant
applications and hopefully we can
identify gaps where researchers aren't
applying and we can then address those
gaps
so I want to thank my small team for
introducing me to R and all the tools
and packages that I've shown you today I
think we've definitely been able to have
an outsized impact for such a small team
and you know I hope we can use the the
lessons that we've learned and the tools
that we've developed to continue to
support an ad in the future with their
goal of uh you know to better understand
treat and ultimately prevent infectious
diseases and to improve human health so
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]